A couple weeks ago I got a haircut that was definitely too short.
My bangs are a lot shorter than I want them in.
The back of my head is something that I don't even wanna talk about.
So in order to fix it, I need to make my hair grow as quickly as I can.
I started by making some Rosemary water.
Let my Rosemary simmer in some water for about 15 minutes,
let it cool, and then transferred it over to my spray bottle.
Once that was set aside, I started on my Rosemary hair oil.
I combined some olive oil,
but you can also use avocado or coconut.
Put some clean Rosemary sprigs in,
let that infuse on a double boiler,
and about 45 minutes later take it off and let it cool.
I combined some argan oil,
jojoba, vitamin E,
sweet almond oil, and some peppermint oil.
Poured in my Rosemary infused olive oil,
gave that a good mix and bottled it up.
Spray the Rosemary water all over my scalp
and also the length of my hair
before the oil,
massage it into my scalp and let it sit before washing it out.